democracy undeniably the best Greek
export that doesn't have fruit at the
bottom there is understandable concern
at the moment about the personalities
harming our democracy but tonight let's
talk about one of the major structural
problems and it's something that
Democrats in particular love to complain
about we have seen Republicans rigged
the system with their gerrymandering
often illegal gerrymandering there is
gerrymandering to a fare-thee-well in
states controlled by the Republicans
listen political gerrymandering is
probably one of the greatest threats to
our democracy right now well slow down
that is a bit much the greatest threat
to our democracy right now is clearly
whatever tweet the president has planned
for Cinco de Mayo this year we don't
know yet what it will be we don't know
which Spanish words will be misspelled
or we can assume it will be horrifying
but gerrymandering is a real problem
it's the practice of drawing voting
districts in a way that create unfair
advantages to whoever happens to be
drawing the lines which which does sound
mundane but the results can be
significant gerrymandering is partly
responsible for giving Republicans such
an edge in the House of Representatives
because take a look at what happened in
some states where they drew the district
lines in Pennsylvania 44% of the voters
chose Democratic candidates for the
House of Representatives in 2014 but 13
of the 18 districts more than two-thirds
are represented by Republicans in Ohio
about 40% of the voters chose Democratic
candidates for the House of
Representatives but 12 out of 16 seats
3/4 of them are represented by
Republicans those numbers are way out of
proportion to what people should expect
you wouldn't accept Neapolitan ice cream
that was 75% strawberry how is that okay
what perverts voted for this
so whoever draws the district's has a
lot of power and thanks to technological
advances it's possible to use that power
in very precise ways in the age of
computers you can gerrymander with
scientific precision you can run in and
out of alleys and up and down streets so
carefully include and exclude whichever
voters you want in one district and not
in another so it's become a very precise
science he's right about that
gerrymandering has become a very precise
science and interestingly it's one of
the few remaining types of science in
which the Republican Party currently
believes now now there are different
reasons
politician to engage in gerrymandering
it's done to disadvantage voters based
on race or on political party or to
shore up seats for incumbents sometimes
even within a party take her team
Jefferies
in 2000 he run a strong challenge in a
Democratic primary for the New York
State Assembly and he planned to run
again in 2002 but the Democrats had done
something interesting to the map the map
that was drawn was absolutely
fascinating they drew a map that
literally carved out the block on which
Hakeem Jeffries lived from assembly
district 57 I remember shaking my head
in disbelief there were a lot of people
hoping to vote for me but was surprised
to find that they no longer lived in the
Assembly District that they have been
living in for years if not decades
Brooklyn politics can be pretty rough
but that move was gangsta yes it was
gangsta I remember the threshold for
gangsta in Brooklyn is be notorious
b.i.g whose debut album begins with
songs that are respectively about armed
robbery
gun violence armed robbery and gun
violence and being prepared to die by
gun violence while committing armed
robbery I think if I know means a new
problem
even the term gerrymandering goes back
centuries it gets its name from a 19th
century politician in Elbridge Gerry as
governor of Massachusetts he helped
shape a congressional district so
blatantly one-sided that one critic said
it looked like a salamander no another
replied a gerrymander
now that counted as a joke in 1810 back
when your entertainment options were
sunsets Washington Irving novels and
getting kicked by a horse
and quick sidenote you are not wrong to
notice that the Jerry in gerrymander
refers to a guy whose name was actually
pronounced Gary because literally
everything about gerrymandering is
stupid and wrong and look there is
nothing inherently wrong with redrawing
a voting district it's actually
necessary they need to have around the
same number of people in them and
populations shift over time as people
move or die or emigrate to America
because their stand up careers have
endured what might be best characterized
as a pogrom of indifference that is why
every ten years we have a census after
which lines are redrawn for both the US
House and state legislatures the problem
is in most states the lines are drawn by
politicians in fact in 37 states the
drawing of state legislative districts
is primarily controlled by the
legislators themselves and they have a
pretty clear vested interest there and
if you think that seems crazy you're not
alone let me fall I speak to five or six
members of the British Parliament could
come over to shadow members of Congress
and one of the things I have to explain
to them is here's how you get elected
the house I have you know I see the
shocked looks on these British faces and
one time one stood up and said well
that's terrible that's not the voters
choosing their representatives that's
the representatives choosing their
voters first that's racist and second
second even I find it difficult hearing
advice on map drawing in a British
accent that one said I don't see why one
scrap of dust is any different from
another so I ended the border here
because that's where my pen ran out of
ink now learn to like it what's the
worst that can happen but it is true
that if your party holds the
redistricting pen
it will substantial power and there are
multiple techniques at its disposal
there are a couple of ways that you can
reapportioned people and put them into
districts and there's a thing called
packing and there's a thing called
cracking yes packing
and cracking not to be confused with the
team drug trend of cracking and packing
which is when the teens hollow out a
cucumber fill it with crack and put it
in their anus to absorb it faster I saw
it on the local news which means it's
real and every teenager is doing it
right now
but in this context packing these
cramming as many Opposition voters as
possible into just a few districts and
cracking means spreading them out thinly
over a bunch of districts so they can't
gain a majority in any one of them
either way it dilutes their impact I
can't think of it as table assignments
at a wedding you can either break up
your eight awful relatives and spread
them out over different tables or you
can pack them all together in one
insufferable table of the Damned
The Washington Post showed how this can
work look at this hypothetical state
it's 60% blue voters 40% red and it
needs to be carved up into five
districts now proportionally you would
want three blue and two red districts
but if you draw the lines like this you
can get three red majorities and two
glues and if you draw it like this
you can get five blue majorities and no
red and if you draw lines like this it
looks like a dick which is irrelevant to
this discussion it is objectively very
funny and if you are thinking shouldn't
all of this be illegal well that's
complicated because if you're
gerrymandering to disadvantaged
minorities yes that is illegal under the
Voting Rights Act but if you're
gerrymandering to disadvantaged voters
of an opposing party that has generally
been allowed so racial gerrymandering no
partisan gerrymandering that's kind of
okay and it's led politicians to be
pretty brazen in their behavior like in
North Carolina last year their
congressional map was thrown out in
federal courts for racial gerrymandering
which is wrong so they had to redraw and
while doing it state Rep David Lewis
went out of his way to explain that the
new map would not illegally over
minorities it would just legally buckle
the Democrats we want to make clear
that we to the extent are going to use
political data in drawing this map it is
to gain partisan advantage on the map
I want that criteria to be clearly
stated and understood I need you to
understand this is not a race thing
because it can't be we just want to map
the churns out Republicans like if Ann
Romney that is all we say that is all we
are saying here
please let me understand and that map
worked in 2016 despite Republicans
winning just over half the votes in
House races they wound up controlling
77% of the state seats that is a more
blatant disregard for what people want
then the who gives out Bazooka
Joe on Halloween oh great
gum from the Roosevelt administration
wrapped in a comic from the other
Roosevelt administration at least the
guy handing out snicker stuff with razor
blades actually gives you a Snickers and
Republicans elevated this technique to
an art form with a plan called read map
or the redistricting majority project
they poured more than 13 million dollars
into state level races ahead of the last
redistricting gaining huge numbers of
seats and that paid massive dividends
when Republicans won the majority of
state houses in 2010 it ensured they'd
be redrawing the maps in those states
and long before it paid off in 2012
nationwide Democrats running for
Congress got 1.1 million more votes but
Republicans sent 33 more members to the
house exactly so the maps they drew put
Democrats at a significant disadvantage
it's like if instead of Tim Duncan the
San Antonio Spurs and had to use Tim
Burton it's not technically impossible
to win but it's going to be much much
harder and look to some extent
Republicans got lucky because 2010 was a
wave election for their party and I'm
not saying Democrats are angels here by
no means when they have had control
they've gerrymandered the out of
districts in states like Maryland and
they've been pretty brazen too
Illinois in 2001 the Democrats won the
right to redistricting issues for
reasons too complicated and too stupid
to explain a name was pulled out of a
replica of Abraham Lincoln stovepipe at
but but just watch as one Democratic
lawmaker made the least convincing
promise ever well will they'll sit down
in draw a very fair map an inherently
suspicious look on his face that's the
exact expects of someone who just
urinated in the public pool water's warm
today huh
enjoy your swim so how do you know if
your district has been drawn with
nefarious intent well that's tricky
because too often people will just
lazily point to districts that have a
weird shape north carolina's 12th
district looks like spilled coffee
Pennsylvania's 16th is flexing its
muscles and one commentator compared
Maryland's third to a broken-winged
pterodactyl and then there's this they
call it the earmuffs oh yes an earmuffs
district not to be confused with the aim
of district which is a one block area of
Manhattan we're sketchy men sell
accessories made from the third
endangered species you should go you
should visit but while it is tempting to
see something suspicious in an
odd-shaped district there is a pretty
good argument against prioritizing tidy
lines above all else dropping a bunch of
squares seems fair it seems like if you
could just draw a grid like Tron that
you could put people into districts and
there wouldn't be any sort of
manipulation in the process but
Americans don't live the exception of
Montana and you know a few other square
places Americans don't live in squares
our communities are irregular and random
yes that's true American communities are
not square
they're like jazz music they're freeform
free-flowing and they contain a
troubling amount of opioids and there is
no one right way to draw a district
reasonable people will disagree
some might prioritize of districts being
politically competitive
others might favor compactness others
want to keep so-called communities of
interest together the problem is it may
be physically impossible to do all three
of those things in one place in fact
take that earmuff district at the thin
line connecting the two halves is just a
single road and people love to make fun
of that in Chicago squeezed between two
freeways this narrow strip is needed to
connect two halves of a gerrymandered
district to keep it contiguous as is
required this is the way Congress gets
around the contiguous rule because
there's obviously nobody living here I
mean unless they're homeless people I
guess anybody here any congressional
voters out there now you might laugh but
a few seconds later an entire ghost
baseball team from the early nineteen
hundred's walk out of the store lost and
beaten to death with their ghost bag and
he's kind of deserved it but but here is
the thing though it is drawn like ear
muffs for good reasons because the
northern and southern parts are to
Latino communities and the district in
the middle is predominantly
african-american now both are Democratic
so it's not about partisan advantage
it's about ensuring that both
communities have representatives serving
their interests and it's criticized a
lot but redistricting it experts
absolutely love it in fact two of them
actually put it on their wedding cake
that is a real wedding cake and I'm
guessing that the bachelorette party
cake was something like one more night
of packing and cracking so so to break
it down
not all weird shake districts are bad
and not all normal shake districts are
good and there is one more thing
gerrymandering is not the sole reason
for the mismatch between our popular
vote percentages and our representation
some of that is due to where Democrats
choose to live Democrats live in the
wrong places basically they've decided
to cram themselves in cities and that
just makes it really hard to have a
winning coalition when your people do
that if you're college-educated if you
want to work in the creative economy you
move to a city and those places have
enough Democrats already Democrats they
do play make places like Des Moines or
Columbus or Raleigh North Carolina
all so that those young people move
there but that's kind of outside the
typical realm of political strategy wait
what do you mean make Des Moines cool
I've already got the Des Moines Heritage
carousel the most badass
balls-to-the-wall carousel in the whole
Midwest and yes according to their
website it is closed for the season of
spring which is not a good time for
carousel but when May 28th it's going to
be an all-out carousel Stravaganza
until 8 p.m. but it is true Democrats
are basically packing themselves into
districts and that is not likely to
change anytime soon but there is a
broader non partisan point here and that
is the inner democracy the question of
who gets to draw the map should not have
as much significance as it currently
does now there is actually a Supreme
Court case coming up involving a
redistricting in Wisconsin there was so
partisan a lower court struck their maps
down and the Supreme Court may for the
first time actually issue a clear ruling
putting limits on partisan
gerrymandering so all of our hopes are
now we need delicious claws of Justice
neo-gothic but even without a ruling
many experts argue we should simply be
taking redistricting out of the hands of
politicians and give the task to
independent commissions and that's a
pretty good idea in fact a handful of
states already do some version of that
and it's not perfect it is tough to
completely remove parties and biases a
fact that one state lawmaker brought up
to shoot the idea down if I felt there
were any way in the world that I could
stand before my constituents and say I
believe that it's possible to come up
with a group of people who have no
political bias whatsoever who will
simply sit down in a room and magically
create districts I'd be behind it I'd be
behind it a hundred percent but those
people don't exist now if you recognize
that guys because you saw him about ten
minutes ago
reassuring everyone in intensive Roy
districts was to gain parties an
advantage for Republicans so eventually
arguing
nobody's unbiased so let's use me the
most brazenly biased man in the universe
which is pretty much arguing no
babysitter is perfect so let's just use
Slenderman but while independent
Commission's might not be perfect they
would definitely be better and the truth
is it is hard to come up with a worse
system than the one most states
currently have and there is something
very important at stake here
lawmakers should not be allowed to
dilute our votes by drawing their own
lines and essentially picking their own
voters no you know what I will tell you
why the foundations of democracy are
built on the idea that everybody's vote
should count equally everybody that is
what America is all about
that everyone every one of us to get an
equal chance to make a bad decision
which things up for everybody else
whoever we are however poor our
decisions whether you are a Juggalo will
stop it or a 47 year olds Quidditch
player it's a school or or someone who
bought that stupid $6,000 jacket I wore
on the sell last week it's horrible our
boy recently fully hurt even if we
Scientologists or Parrotheads or guys
who ride unicycles as their primary mode
of transportation in this one context we
should all be relevant regardless of our
questionable life choices whether you're
an easy Ambrose or a guy jamming a knife
into a toaster or a Washington Redskins
fan or even a guild Stein support he
went one how would she of one what
process could give you so the point is
her voice should count as much as anyone
elses as much as a guy in a fedora or a
beta of erotic pastries or a SantaCon
attendee or everyone's racist grandma
don't say anything if at the end of the
day that is the point of this country
that's what made America great because
think about it
results should not be the fault of
lawmakers crazy lines they could be the
result of our only play these decisions
[Applause]